a phrase that's supposed to be in the
rear view mirror by now well far from it
the united kingdom and the eu are still
talking about changes to the
arrangements for northern ireland and
foreign secretary liz truss is in the
newspapers today saying she's going to
take unilateral action and invoke
article 16 to rip up parts of the
current agreement if they can't find a
new solution
so is there going to be a deal
and what happens if there isn't
the eu ambassador to the uk valley de
almeida joins me now
uh good morning uh mr valedile um
do you think that there is a prospect uh
of uh the article 15 being invoked by
the government uh soon
well good morning trevor or i should
rather say so trevor congratulations
uh and and happy new year you're the
first of my guests to tease me about it
this morning but on the go well i think
it's
well deserved well deserved and the
happy new year to you and all the all
the viewers and our friends in the
united kingdom listen we heard this
before from the government so we are not
surprised we are not too impressed but
we still believe it's not very helpful
that we keep you know agitating the
issue of article 16. um
i think what we should focus on at least
that's where we are focused on is trying
to find solutions uh for difficulties in
the implementation of the protocol but
let me remind you uh so trevor of a very
simple point
the problems arise and were
triggered by brexit not by the protocol
the protocol tries to mitigate the
serious problems created in northern
ireland by the brexit and the kind of
brexit that that was chosen so we are
focused on solutions invoking article 16
or invoking issues which are not the
core concern
of citizens and business in northern
ireland and we have been listening to
them very attentively so doing article
16 or enlarging the scope of problems is
not going to contribute to find
solutions
uh by the way uh trevor is fine for this
program so trevor only happens when i
have my horse with me but just coming
back to the point in hand um
do you don't you think that
essentially the clock is ticking here
liz truss is going to meet the uh
leader in northern ireland to jeffrey
donaldson this week and at some point
soon we are going to have to have a
solution is it time for everybody to get
their skates on and start
bringing forward some new compromises
absolutely we we we need a new momentum
in these talks and we are eager to
reconnect with the british government
now with the foreign secretary and
looking forward to meetings
in a few days in in in britain and uh we
are eager to reconnect but we are even
more eager
to find compromises uh because we need
to move on it's been too long just to
give you an example
we have listened attentively to sir
jeffrey and many other leaders uh to all
the leaders actually in northern ireland
we have engaged with the civil society
we have engaged with business my first
official visit out of london was to
northern ireland vice president
chefkovich was the interlocutor of lee
strauss has been there as well as in in
constant contact we identified the
problems and in october we put forward a
very ambitious package of measures that
deals with all the main issues the core
concerns the difficulties in
implementing the protocol we now want
this to be
fully discussed and i hope that
at least we expect that from the british
government to reciprocate on our offer
of october and and get down to
concrete practical uh solutions that's
that's our spirit that's our approach
that's our mindset as we approach and we
prepare for the meetings in the in the
coming days
uh there of course is another um
event approaching that will put new
pressure on these negotiations and that
is uh that there will be elections to
the stormont assembly in may and in
practice
when this gets mixed up with
politics
does that is that likely to make the
negotiation even more complicated
i don't want to comment on the internal
situation of of a third country
which i well i proudly represent the
european union but i can tell you that
we've been we are in close contact with
all the political leaders in northern
ireland
directly or or virtually on a very
regular basis and i think we fully
understand all the elements of the
complexity of the situation in northern
ireland the the european union has been
committed for a long time to peace and
prosperity in northern ireland we were
there since the beginning of the good
friday belfast agreement and we remain
absolutely committed to guarantee peace
and security and prosperity in order
tonight and actually if i may trevor uh
highlight one point the protocol
provides a huge opportunity for northern
ireland just remember that this is the
only territory in the world that has
access to both the united kingdom market
but also to
half a billion people market which is
the single market of the european union
so the only territory in the world so
this gives not an island citizens not an
island business a perspective for job
creation for foreign investment for
european investment but also i
understand canadian american investors
are very interested provided we
guarantee that there is predictability
and security and stability in northern
ireland i think the protocol creates the
conditions for that against the
background of a brexit that created
enormous problems for northern ireland
we had to square the circle together
with our british friends it took a long
time now we have the protocol which is
international law british law eu law we
want to implement it with pragmatism
with a certain degree of flexibility
and that's what we're talking about and
that's what we should talk about in the
coming days and weeks and i share the
idea that we need a new momentum and i
hope that the meeting we're having in
chivening uh this week with the foreign
secretary will inject a new momentum
into these negotiations that's our hope
and that's our commitment
my turn to a
rather different challenge uh to the eu
and foreign uh affairs and that is of
course
the fact that dozens of protesters and
12 police officers at least we think
have died in
ongoing violence in kazakhstan
russia has sent troops across the border
um
how worried is the eu about russian
incursion into its neighbors
well it's good that you mentioned russia
is good that you mentioned situation in
in kazakhstan because this is one area
of security in our neighborhood this is
one area where the eu and uk can do a
lot together and my my sense in looking
at the wider picture is that the sooner
we move on
from uh you know
issues that are still open related to
brexit in particular the north atlantic
situation the sooner we move on from
that
uh the better equipped we will be
the eu and the uk to work together in
addressing very serious issues uh
what can you do mr putin is not um
mr putin
doesn't do much uh uh responding to warm
words does he i mean what can you
actually do to stop well i think i think
i think
uh you know i was in liverpool in the in
the g7 foreign affairs ministers chaired
by by lee strauss and uh we together
agreed a very strong uh statement uh the
european union member states have a very
common position of strength the united
states is together the nato allies are
together and we are saying very clearly
uh and these are very clear words that
there will be massive consequences and
severe cost if russia
adventures into into ukraine with
military action and this is a very very
solid and unified position among
ourselves as you know today tomorrow the
days after there will be important
diplomatic
initiatives taking place i forgive you
too interrupting the
massive consequences that's that's a
good phrase would one massive
consequence be for the eu to say to mr
putin
if you keep on like this you can forget
about nordstream 2 and that flow of
revenue from oil and gas into western
europe i don't think we should
anticipate action
we should react when action takes place
what we're doing now is trying to
de-escalate using all the diplomatic
tools and avenues that are available if
ever
russia
moves into other direction they can be
sure that there will be a unified
response from our side and let me give
you this also as an example of the need
for us to move on in our bilateral
relationship because we are we share the
same values we share the same strategic
interests and there's a lot we need to
do regarding our neighborhood but also
regarding iran where we have a very
clear joint position with uk our
relationship with other parts of the
world thank you and the cooperation with
the us so it's a long list
and that is awaiting a better climate
thank you ambassador thank you so much